It's not funny that the fire is suddenly eating Pepero
Ah, in a country where acceptance is controversial,
I eat quite a bit
here
.
[Music]
Ah,
I'm so mine, so I
'm so hot
.
As for the diet with this, it's
a great long but very tasty food. It's really delicious
by itself. Eat
this in a combo with tteokbokki
. Oh, give me the original energy. It
's not a 1 jack food.
When we sold Parktel, it was the time we had to introduce ourselves
. Then we will meet a miracle like
this
Take
off her toe, it's up to you. This song is a national
snack, so a
recommendation.
Her personal concerns are almonds, almonds, and
peperos.
I love them so much, but they have their own
festival schedule. That's right.
I
ask for this to look like almonds, and I like this
. There are various types of
tea, and there are many different types of tea. If I just
eat a lot, I get my taste. Details
I think it's
tea for one's taste.
Here again, I
can't find this
. This is where there is too much monitoring in Korea now. This
was made with a croissant. Such an idea is
to use this machine to make waffles like this, and it's
called croup.  I
put it on uh ah ah, I have to
eat ice cream on top of it.
Oh now, with cream, I put it in a
cup, and on the 1st day,
I will ask if there is any proof even after Wang Young-
eun's quarter.  It's
spacious and I keep 5 chocolates again
. But this one
is not what Witch students eat. It's
not. It's not. It's not. It's
delicious. What is the original
fire?  It’s
okay to read and it’s so different that it’s a different story Usher,
so it could be, so it could still be just a
story, right?
The members say,
now that we usually shoot in groups, we
always meet a lot on set. That's
right, but when you think about the time we met, it seems like the first time we met
each other quickly, we
didn't put up a wall rather than a dog.
It's not
like that. It's not like that. It's like this. It's like this. I'm
filming this today. I'm diabetic, so
send me a whole grape
.
Just go back, Kuma is just
20,000 won more uh that's actually a spoonful of a
gun kim ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah,
you know that Nano is a sin,
this is the devil's cream
We
just need to eat. Let's do a track like that. Ugh, but now it's a pharmacist cancer. I'm counting with the
next toothbrush.
I think I'm going to have an insulin shock. Honey, it's hard to control myself because I'm next to you.
Hey everyone, we shared
our favorite stack garden with you. Did you enjoy it
? It must be delicious.
4 And we also love our Jo Mi-ae, or communal economic
zone, and
I hope you enjoy watching it. Thank you
[Music
] Which one of the two was
It's okay
Oh, it's too much weather and it's time
to be ignorant like this